une cérémonie présidée par le préfet
deux autres lui même et douze maires qui
reçoivent la marianne du civisme
l'instant est solennel toutes ces
communes on est le plus fort taux de
participation aux dernières élections le
vote c'est une obligation est un droit
on va voir les élections européennes
l'an prochain il ya beaucoup
d'abstention c'est important d'envoyer
un signal notamment vis-à-vis des jeunes
alors pour mieux comprendre ce vote
massif
nous nous sommes rendus dans l'une des
communes récompensées vauconcourt
nerveuse en 220 habitants à une
trentaine de kilomètres de bozouls
par exemple pour les ions présidentielle
2017 on était quasiment à 10% au-dessus
des moyennes départementales pour les
pressions étaient à 80 % de
participation au premier ou au deuxième
tour contre à peu près 80% au niveau
départemental et si on se compare une
ville comme vésoul par exemple je sais
ce vide un petit peu une caractéristique
du département on est tellement à 20
points au dessus puisque vesoul c'était
plutôt 70 % de participation
poussons la porte du café du village
pour rencontrer des habitants dans ce
lieu de vie en échange de ses idées on
discute on prend des nouvelles des uns
des autres
on sent un petit peu délaissé en
campagne on est dans nos petits villages
on pense que ben dans les villes ils
nous oublient un peu donc évidemment oui
oui oui c'est dans les petits villages
je pense qu'on votre on veut très très
bien et pourquoi plus ici alors le
civisme voilà juste la convivialité ben
oui oui bien sûr la convivialité
pourquoi on vote plus ici qu'ailleurs
plus parce qu'on a envie d'être
représentés par des gens peut-être
qu'ils seraient de terrain déjà parce
que en principe tous ceux de la route
ils sont pas de terrain et puis ne
connaissent pas nos problèmes le bus
arrive les enfants rentrent de l'école
cette nouvelle génération qui demain
aura le droit de vote est ici à vos
concours nerveuse ans comme dans
d'autres communes de haute saône
la marianne du civisme compte bien
s'installer dans le temps et rendez vous
est pris pour les élections européennes
en 2019